yippee-ki-yay movie lovers its Chan here
if you've watched my review of Mahina
you'll know I really enjoyed the
animated feature so in this video I want
to look at the five funniest moments
from the film obviously there will be
spoilers ahead of you haven't seen the
film already and if that's you you can
check out my spoiler free review in the
movie right here and do come back and
watch this video after you've seen it by
the way I've got a fab giveaway to win
this gorgeous the art of Disney's won a
hardback book from Abrams and Chronicle
it'll be on my Moana Easter Egg video so
make sure you subscribe and I'll add a
link to the video here as soon as it's
ready kicking us off at number 5 is a
scene where Maui steals mallanna's boats
and sails off even taking along with
Anna's rooster sidekick hey hey as a
snack for later
it's especially funny when were on an
escape from the cave where the trickster
demigod trapped her and launches herself
into the air to try and catch it with
Maui on the boat but Jesus misses it and
lands splat in the sea and I love how
Maui react saying I could watch that all
day okay enjoy the Island Maui out then
he tries to get away but the ocean has
other ideas and carries Moana back onto
the canoe again and again despite Mary's
repeated attempt to get rid of her it's
just a little slapstick scene but it's
still very amusing when hey hey Stow's
away on - bows and she finds him once
they've set sail that moment is so funny
when Moana takes a half coconut shell
off hey his head and he realizes where
he actually is not on dry land with
rocks to peck at and swallow but instead
surrounded by water in the middle of the
ocean and he lets out a piercing scream
which only stops each time Alana puts
the coconut shell back on his head
I love the magnificently crazy action
scene were a boatload of teeny-tiny
pirates wearing armor made of coconut
shells attack Moana Maui on the high
seas there's so many of them that
they're absolutely everywhere ziplining
on Samanas boat swiping hey hey who
swallowed the Harter to Fiji and
suddenly telling their one ship in two
three there's loads of fun in this
fast-paced scene including the [ __ ]
amaura's accidentally shooting their own
chief with a blow dart and the owner
gets some badass action fighting the
coconutty pirates as does Maui who sails
their boat through the ever narrowing
gap between two rapidly emerging Kakkar
Moro vessels
it's all very Mad Max fury road so
what's not to love and who can forget
when Moana first meets Maui thanks to an
exceptionally charismatic performance by
Dwayne Johnson who lends his voice to
the big headed big muscled demigod now
he's so full of himself that not only
does he stop the whine of mid-speech to
make sure she gets his full title
correct it's actually Maui shapeshifter
demigod of the wind and sea hero of men
I interrupted from the top hero of men
gum but he also assumes that what she
really wants is his autograph because he
is after all hero of men and women it's
not a guy girl thing also I really love
your welcome the totally irresistible
song he sings about all his amazing
accomplishments of why he thinks
humankind must be so grateful to him and
the whole scene is made even better by
the way that Maui's tattoos come to life
to tell the story of all his fantastic
feats and the way that mini maui acts as
his voice of reason i absolutely adore
it and at number one is a frankly
fabulous scene where Moana and Maui
outwit the totally blinged up colossal
II conceited crap Tama Toa on their
mission to get Maui's magical fish hook
back I love everything about this bit of
the film especially the incredibly
catchy David Bowie style song that's how
Ottawa sings about how amazing he is I
also loved the way the 50-foot crabs
certainly appears out of what just
looked like a pile of treasure and
hamurana cleverly tricks him by
showering him with compliments appealing
to the fact that he just adores bragging
about himself and it's really funny how
Tama Toa does a sort of running
commentary about what's going on in the
scene
and also how Maui swoops in and grabs
back his hook telling Tama Toa that it's
Maori time Jemaine Clement who voices a
super-sized crustacean is just perfect
and rings out every last drop of comedy
in the scene which is why it's great to
see Tama Toa on-screen again in a
comical post-credit scene where he named
drop Sebastian from the Little Mermaid
is just brilliant okay what are your
favorite moments from the other and
which bits made you laugh out loud the
most I can't wait to read your comments
below I've got videos on the way with
all the Easter eggs and Hidden Mickeys
in Moana plus some cool deleted scenes
from the movie and I'll update the link
here once they're live if you enjoyed
this video thanks for hitting the thumbs
up and share buttons and don't forget to
subscribe for more videos on disney
pixar comic book movies and loads more
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers